yeah welcome to another video and could
we won my opponent I don't know him
let's see okay now an Enzo Queen sit
together some number of good lines I go
96 currently and looking at this line
legs ideas usually to go d 6 35 the term
is playing the normal theoretical moves
this is one of the best lines young hip
hip like has some more than one option I
can do night to h5 for just a good move
and I probably should do that there's
also Bishop g4 possible but then night
at shriver Sam it's ok so g3 saw an f5
he's got knowledge for ya I cannot
cannot go at five now sorry and that
probably his threatening night XD five
hmm ok come on let's let's return this
and maybe I can go home we should 83 at
some point
no I'm sorry I've got time with a sore
throat him atria he wants to prevent
Bishop h3 really hard but how does he
casts on now probably not at all or
maybe he wants to play some some move
like g4 good job well long castles
really okay i try to open up the
queenside let's see em what happens I'm
pretty quick here with opening the side
of the board yep it should be sick son
and to learn look see a droopy ate
something like that I've got to open
lines and he's got nothing in terms of
open lines he's got g45 this is clear
but not quite sure how how dangerous is
really is
yeah what strange move mmm yeah Brooke
to see eight but which look route look a
to c 8 it looks a bit weird you won't
rock on head and rock on see it but look
look f2c am I mean this is done still in
a pin which is some bit annoying but
okay no way I really don't want to play
route 88 this rock really belongs to be
eight so i can take now play not a five
to see for you let's let's go for that
he can go g5 that's clear ok can ok
Knight to f5 but this is really slow I
mean it's just the night there are no
open lines for the rooks and then this
should should mean something now
threatening night takes a three at night
XD five night XD five feet Lori has
looked e5 so must be cautious so just
just this one right and there really
should be some substantial threats
coming up
yeah 9555 this is a bit unlucky in this
97 I'll move but I don't really see how
he defends his position now I mean I can
just um increase the the pressure on the
on the king who gathers this really
calls for Knight takes a three or or
queen 86 also not bad not bad looking
but Knight takes a 3m doesn't really
seem to win outright has also got 97 on
Queen a 60 Queen a sick son is somewhat
weird but it cannot take on c8 anyway
because of Queen a three okay so let's
go here on a4ai thought just Knight a5
with the idea of taking 1b 397 I can
just go to f/8 there shouldn't be a big
problem at least not immediately I need
to play a for anyway RL sudhir should
defend a 3
think a 4 95 97 king of eight nights c8
night xp3 really not sure how convincing
this is maybe I should go to be 6 really
come on let's let's go to be 697 King f8
take stakes I've got done and I just
attacked e5 also so I'll get the d5 pawn
with some still a strong attack to to
boot maybe this one so that night a4 is
a possibility so take now
ok let's threaten night a four-night c4
takes Queen textbook be three and then
Knight c3 is the idea 6 the sign was
checker completely overlooked that oh
man ok just Nick I just can take this
exam King g8's ok didn't see that so
this was probably probably winning fan
Jack just getting the rope gun huh check
check check check check I've been too
slow unbelievable I what a game yeah of
course um maybe I shouldn't have
returned the queen but I thought this
would be would be the simplest for them
just not not quick enough ok he could
have taken d 60m and probably am this is
oh it's so it's actually winning for
black hmm surprising well I didn't
really calculate further so this is
willing young cool and so just check
briefly how yeah after this yeah I made
Queen a four it's an additional
additional problem and this move I can
go here and now queen deform Wow well
I'm not really sure if I would have seen
that this is the only move I go on let's
say night to be from yeah this is also
winning this looks more natural to me
Queen a to this is also when he doesn't
have have a move you can see one that's
93 and turn this is all so decisive so
yeah I had to add a brick a check here
but I probably am played this okay so
night a three was winning here King a
three night night takes King takes an IT
form this is very strong community a 6am
also keeps a winning position but makes
it more complicated and now the computer
just wants to go rugby seven yeah it
certainly am make some sense covering e7
and so on and this probably i'm sposed
the advantage yeah it's still quite okay
for black but not winning any more TM
adhere black his willing again he needs
to go Queen d3 yeah I expected this move
Queen III because I need to retreat that
to be seven I mean black has got a good
position with the two pawns or with not
with the two points i get t five but
I've got two points in the scent and
quite a disc compensation but you need
sir needs to do that
yeah all right the done lucky at the end
time thanks for watching